tonight Claire Danes John Karin
PewDiePie are all gonna play Mario card
together
it's 4:30 Texas here how the [ __ ] am I
gonna get this closed this is way too
much stuff oh my god
[Music]
well damn that was easier than I thought
bye house all right I'm really sad we're
leaving this but we gotta go I just feel
like forgot something okay now I'm ready
to go
[Music]
every time in the uber they give you
water every time but not the only time
I'm so thirsty
I need water
Wow
Oh hallelujah
I've never seen Marcel walk this fast
like I should be scared we're almost
mystified because my water
we made it gotta sleep welcome back to
plants there's bad weather
okay I'm in New York with my sister
yeah and my mother we're gonna have
dinner and tomorrow's the big day
really good you think it whereas a
nightclub they look good here
65 apparently someone recognized you on
the plane as my sister is that Greg oh
really
it's only 8:00 p.m. but I feel like
we're just going to go back and this
will probably be a super boring ploy
right
my mom is playing Pretty Polly legend of
the brofist what do you think of the
game is it a game really terrible okay
it's 12 I just realized that never did
an outro I fell asleep oh I fell asleep
I like bait and then jet lag is jet lag
but this city is damn beautiful at night
oh my my yeah time for me to go
thanks ding ding oh ok we got fake put
if I go nothing so they're setting up my
setup for like a sketch or something
like that so it looks like it would be
my dad or something daddy PI or
something you to space looks so fancy
look at this all these great tools okay
so I'm here doing an interview can you
see myself can I see there thanks for
that it was really fun I think it went
well ok I'm back in the hotel great
audio in here I had like 10 minutes to
rest and now we're going back because
now I'm gonna be on live television with
Steven freakin Kolbert and I'm really
nervous tonight Claire Danes John Kerry
and PewDiePie are all gonna play Mario
Kart together but we're stuck in traffic
so I don't know if you'll make it there
how you feeling again feel pumped
these pants fit me perfectly because
they're tailored watch the TV the more
nervous I guess you're gonna be great
this is so weird yay yes I'll put on my
fireplace YouTube celebrities let's play
youtube videos please welcome everyone
bro and the man they call you were so
good oh my god
I finished it what is going on I was
super nervous but it worked out well
Steven was such an easy guy to talk to
one of the coolest guys ever met so cool
I'm really excited it's over and I can't
wait for you guys to see it now we're
just gonna have some drinks and dinner
and yes
okay everyone wave
can't wait to sleep I almost feel
emotional because my parents were here
and well my mom and my sister I still
can't believe what just happened such a
huge thing to be on the Stephen Colbert
show he was such a cool guy this is
really cool I never thought I would get
to a point like this and it's awesome
I'm just really proud it's a big day a
memorable day for sure and I'm glad I
got to bring you Bros along with with me
on this day that's it thanks for
watching I'll see you tomorrow it's the
last vlog let that sink for a minute I
can't stop eating these Swedish potato
chips and you know prolong Swedish
people will relate today I'm a tourist I
feel like I'm going insane I spend so
much time packing if I touch it it will
explode they keep calling because they
want us to check out and the EC doesn't
work and I we're taking a walk to
Central Park
it's raining so much why are we here
whis came from the rain we just had
lunch a dis checked and pewdiepie legend
of the brofist is now number three but
we're still before minecraft so that's
the museum metropole ian art you're
gonna check it out because it's raining
and we don't know what else to
oh my face when I wake up too early
[Music]
we're going in here but we don't know
why here we clearly have domesticated
all okay this is kind of cool and I drop
my umbrella
that is pretty at me
there we go the creepy area yes Mike
then they had dildos on their chins this
place is so epic okay
this is like a tiny piece I it's such an
epic Museum it's like a tiny piece of it
I'm blown away I got a great angle over
here such a pimp love it
what is they please don't touch the
window very cool if you got a chance to
go I highly recommend it it just doesn't
end we've been to like three parts out
of ten what you're doing they're bright
they play my game we have like six hours
and do a lot of playing so we're just
chilling relaxing the mechs mechs and I
can't wait to see the pugs alright it's
time to go home so I'm gonna teleport in
three two one
I'm home oh hey hey hey hey alright
that's the end of the LA vlog see you
never again I'm just kidding it's been
amazing I'm gonna I have seven days and
then I'm not actually leaving again so
there will be a seven day break and then
maybe I'll do it again I don't know let
me know if you want to see more thank
you for watching all these vlogs have
been an amazing adventure so much has
happened I feel like I grew as a person
it swishes weird it's true that's all
for me for now and as always stay
awesome brush who came up with this idea
who thought this was a good idea no this
book loves you it's the first time I
hold it in my hat Jeff are you excited
he's excited he's so excited